[Music]
today we're gonna talk first a little
bit about the big picture and then we'll
get into building our application and
we're gonna attempt to do today is build
a web app that is fault tolerant and
scalable we're gonna do it using
kubernetes Engine and cloud sequel as
our back-end database what you see in
this diagram is that we're going to opt
to deploy kubernetes Engine and cloud
sequel in to failure domains in multiple
failure domains where these are
represented by Google Cloud zones within
a region where a zone is essentially a
failure domain within a region so we're
gonna deploy these across zones we're
gonna see how things scale and then
we'll inject some faults and kind of
simulate disaster striking so to speak
before we get there we'll do a little
introduction on kubernetes engine itself
as well as cloud sequel I think by show
of hands at least there are a number of
folks in the audience who haven't had
experience with kubernetes engine and
potentially not with cloud sequel yeah
thanks Brett so back in the early 2000s
Google was off indexing you know the
whole world wide web and you know its
goals to build a service at planetary
planetary scale where anyone around the
world basically can get a response back
in milliseconds right but when you go
back 12 14 years ago Google was like any
company you see today applications were
built running on top of infrastructure
and there was a stupendous e on the
underlying infrastructure and we knew we
needed to scale and really scale quickly
so we went off and tried to solve two
very discrete problems number one right
how do you take a workload and deploy it
on a machine and do it predictably and
then deploy a variety of workloads on
the same machine right so you get better
efficiency and then how do you take this
machine and attach it to a pool of
compute right so as developers you just
write code and you don't really care
where that application ends up running
right that's what we went off to solve
back then and now is really the advent
of containers Google has been using
containers for many years
over a decade back in you know about
fourteen years ago we open sourced a lot
of the work around see groups that
really help running containers in
isolation and so forth so as you look at
where Google is today everything at
Google actually runs inside a container
all our services right from ads search
as a matter of fact for Google cloud or
virtual machines are actually running
inside a container and we spin up over
four billion containers per week a lot
of the work that we did around
containers really led to the creation of
an internal system Google uses called
Borg all of our developers that write
applications submit their jobs to Borg
and then board schedules all these
workloads across Google's fleet few
years back with the advent of containers
and the popularity of containers Google
decided to take all the various best
practices associated with running and
operating and managing containers
internally with Borg and create this
open source project called kubernetes
and really that was a Genesis behind
kubernetes that we announced around four
years ago and we open sourced it and the
goal of kubernetes is really to manage
and operate around your container
workloads right it was really inspired
by the best practices that Google had
around running managing and operating
containers internally and the design
premise behind kubernetes is we wanted
it to run anywhere right and and that
was really the the goal of basically
open sourcing it and then working with
the community in terms of providing
support whether you're running it on
Google cloud or running it on any cloud
on bare metal on any virtual
virtualization technology the whole goal
with kubernetes is to make it easy open
flexible and basically the ability to
run it anywhere you want it was written
and go and as I mentioned from day one
we open sourced this and the popularity
of kubernetes right now is it's become
the de facto standard for running and
managing containers in the market really
the success is behind the community
behind it and the API that it brought
or to the to the world when you're
getting started with kubernetes you know
just show of hands how many people
attended the keynote this morning great
so you've probably heard about the
announcements around gke and bringing
the gk experience to on prem and things
of that nature you know before this
announcement getting kubernetes up and
running outside of google cloud really
involved using a mix-and-match of
different tooling it was an inconsistent
experience depending on where you're
running it there are different tools and
we went off and tried to figure out you
know how do we make this consistent but
at Google we have this notion called
separation of concerns right and
although DevOps is a very important
function oftentimes when you give a
developer a double-edged sword we're on
one hand you're asking the right code
and on the other hand you're asking them
to like worry about like debugging
troubleshooting deployments it's not a
very optimal thing to do and at Google
we have different functions we have our
developers and then we have this
specialization called an application ops
person and then we have another
specialization called a cluster ops
person and in the case of kubernetes a
cluster ops person would come along and
create the environment that's your de
zero right and once you have this
environment up and running and you're
provisioned on top of nodes and you've
configured networking and you've set up
all the various agents and containerized
services in the cluster you know it's
not a it's not a simple process and the
cluster administrator really is focused
on getting all that up and running from
there you basically have now this API
that you can use to deploy your
containerized applications in a
consistent fashion and what's that's
available now the application ops person
can come along and deploy their
containerized applications in such a way
where it's resilient its scalable and so
forth so the role of the developer ends
where the role of the application ops
person starts and the role of the
application persons
stops for the role of the cluster admin
starts now you might be wondering you
know how do I do all this in the cloud
well at Google we introduced three years
ago a managed kubernetes service called
google kubernetes engine it's been GA
now for three years it's very much
managed kubernetes it's an API call to
create a cluster we're actually going to
show you demo this our demo is going to
go through everything that we're talking
about and we're gonna do it live but
it's really an API call to create a
cluster you specify how many nodes you
need you specify the region you want
your nodes which zones you want them
deployed in you can specify a whole
bunch of other parameters that will go
through but that's it after a few
minutes you have a cluster now and you
have an API that you can use to actually
run and manage your containerized
applications on top of that kubernetes
engine provides you a level of
automation around node auto-repair right
so your worker nodes where you're
running your applications every three
months there's a new version of
kubernetes and we basically manage give
you the option of specifying if you want
your nodes Auto upgraded if you want
your master auto upgraded if there's an
issue with one of your nodes we'll go in
and we'll repair the node there's
integrated auto scaling with the
underlying virtual machines so you can
configure everything from your container
auto scaling all the way down to your
node auto scaling and again we'll show
you how all that works in our demo with
that let me ask the audience how many of
you have experience with Google Cloud
sequel ok about about a third or so I'll
give a little introduction and of course
you'll see this as we begin to
demonstrate our application deployment
let me start by saying we're cloud
sequel fits in Google's overall database
portfolio the database portfolio in
Google Cloud is large and ever-growing
you see rightmost on the slide a number
of database offerings from our partners
Google cloud has a large partner
ecosystem and we we list here a handful
of database partners who have offerings
on Google cloud this is not an
exhaustive list
leftmost on the slide you see our
in-memory database we pretty recently
launched a managed Redis service so if
you have to Ashley needs take a look at
cloud memory store which recently
launched reticent to beta just right of
Center is our relational portfolio
comprised of cloud spanner and cloud
sequel if you haven't taken a look at
cloud spanner there are a number of
talks going on this week at the
conference and I encourage you to get to
know that product cloud sequel in the
relational portfolio has one core
commitment and that is compatibility we
offer as close to unmodified my sequel
and Postgres as we can so that if your
application works with my sequel or
Postgres it just works with cloud sequel
in today's demonstration we're gonna be
using cloud sequel for Postgres but that
the compatibility story is essentially
cloud sequel score promise in addition
to compatibility cloud sequel aims to
reduce mundane database administration
tasks commonly associated with running
my sequel and Postgres when we think
about the cloud sequel stack and what it
can do I think Tim Kelton from decart
Labs does a good job of summing this up
in terms of how he sees cloud sequel for
his team he notes here that his team is
using cloud sequel at decart lab is
because it allows them to focus their
time on other things things that are
more valuable to them and to their
customers when I tend to think of the
cloud sequel stack I picture this
diagram where this in my mind is what it
takes to run a database yourself you
have left most on the slide a column
that shows essentially the hardware
racking and stacking of servers thinking
about power and cooling for those
servers as you move left we get to the
operating system we're worried about
installation and maintaining updating
that operating system continuing to move
left we finally get to the database
itself we're installing the database
we're keeping a patch we're keeping it
secure we're setting up things like
regular backups for data protection and
finally rightmost in the slide we get
into some advanced kind of things we're
talking about here high availability
setting up replication for scale-out
making decisions about when a database
is unhealthy should we automatically
failover
/ manually and in the breath of this
stack we have to plumb this through to
some monitoring systems so we can take
keep tabs on our environment the goal of
cloud sequel is to turn this technology
stack into an API call so that if you're
a DevOps engineer developer you can set
up with a single API call a very simple
development database or a much more
advanced production database that
includes automatic failover for high
availability and replication for read
scale out again the goal here is
simplify this picture such that this
turns into an API or a few UI clicks as
you'll see in our demo what isn't
covered on this slide and what's not
shown in this diagram is what backs
cloud sequel and Jason from real massive
points this out he notes that cloud
sequel and managed services generally
Google cloud give him and his team peace
of mind because they are backed by
dedicated 24 by 7 SOE teams for cloud
sequel this is the team writing the
automation writing the monitoring to
make sure that our fleet of databases is
healthy and when needed they're the
folks who get on the keyboard to bring
in a healthy database back to life
hopefully that gives you just a feel for
what cloud sequel is let's now talk a
little less and start our building will
remind everybody that what we're
building today is a fairly simple web
application it's about 200 lines of
Python code the language doesn't matter
so much we're taking a web application
that will test and then finally deploy
here in a way that uses kubernetes
engine and clouds sequel to make sure
it's both fault tolerant and scalable
again the picture here illustrates that
we're going to span our application
across two zones so that were fairly
fault tolerant and if all goes well
we're going to throw some faults at it
before we get into this I want to note
two additional key components we're
using we've talked a lot about
kubernetes Engine and cloud sequel we're
going to be introducing the notion of
the cloud sequel proxy and what you see
in this diagram is the proxy is a
client-side installable that makes your
cloud sequel database look local so if
you were to install the proxy on your
laptop and you started you fired it up
at your favorite coffee shop your cloud
sequel
database would appear to be local on
that laptop the cloud sequel proxy
behind the scenes is setting up a secure
tunnel to your database automatically
and to the application that you're
developing you can act like or you or
make it believe that you are running a
local database and you'll see that in
the demo this is really important for
kubernetes engine because we're going to
be starting up pods and bringing them
down rapidly and we want to make sure
that we don't have to deal with things
like whitelisting IP addresses on a
firewall we let the proxy do all that
sort of authentication and connection
for us the other key concept here is
Google Cloud shell how many of you have
used Google Cloud shell that's great so
about about half the room that's
actually more than we thought I read oak
that sometimes cloud shell is one of our
best-kept secrets in GCP cloud shell is
a VM that you get for free provision to
you with your Google Cloud account we're
gonna be using it today as our
development environment because it
includes a lot of useful tools for a
variety of languages including Python it
also includes a docker environment that
we're gonna use as we start to build and
test our application okay with that
Alain let's get into the actual build
itself we're gonna start with a cloud
sequel instance and so you see my
project here and we can adjust the font
as needed so folks can see I'm gonna
start by creating a cloud sequel
instance so let me just zoom in a little
bit okay when you're creating a cloud
sequel instance I'm going to choose
Postgres in this case we answer a few
fairly straightforward questions we'll
say this is our instance name oops
I knew I'd typo right away all right
this is our instance name I'm gonna use
a password that I highly do not
recommend you can all see it here this
is way short and a very prone to
dictionary attack please don't use this
we're gonna deploy cloud sequel and
kubernetes engine in US central
obviously you can you can deploy it in
any region you'd like and I'm gonna pick
Zone B is in Bravo for our instance now
let's ask cloud sequel to take care of
some administration for us as a starting
point I'm in a size cloud sequel here
cloud sequel starts at very small
inexpensive instances
less than $10 a month if you haven't
used cloud sequel and it scales way up
right now 264 core machines this number
is ever increasing you'll see higher
numbers in the future but for today
we'll give cloud sequel say 8 compute
cores and will max out RAM which is
always a good idea for our database we
expect some traffic on our web
application the nice thing about cloud
sequel is you can change these at any
time we can scale up later or scale back
down if we need to
one thing that's a bit less intuitive
when I'm thinking about scaling cloud
sequel or starting it up is scaling my
storage performance in Google cloud and
in cloud sequel performance is scaled by
adding storage capacity and you see that
cloud sequel includes a performance
calculator here which right now is
showing me that we just have a sliver of
the performance we could get from for
our instance here I can increase that
performance by increasing capacity and
I'll give it a little more because again
we think our web app is going to be a
popular one I mentioned that cloud
sequel aims to help manage mundane
database administration tasks and a good
example is the automatic storage
increase this is a simple checkbox in
the create flow what it does is tell
cloud sequel hey keep a keep an eye on
my disk make sure I don't run out of
disk space before I do increase it a
little bit and continue to do that so
that I don't run out of disk space this
I think is a great example of what we're
talking about when we say managing the
mundane I'll leave this checked so that
just in case we don't run out of disk
today or during the demo as we look a
bit more will ask cloud sequel to
automate our backups we'll have it do so
pretty late at night to keep it out of
the way of our production runs during
the day and as a key point I'm gonna
tell cloud sequel that we want to be
highly available when I do this cloud
sequel gets the message that it is some
extra work to do to make sure that this
instance is a bit more fault tolerant
okay with those options selected I'm not
going to bother authorizing any networks
we're gonna let the cloud sequel handle
our key our connection security for us
and I won't bother setting up any more
configuration we'll just go ahead and
create our instance a cloud sequel
instance takes about three minutes to
create so fortunately for all of you I
have very Martha Stewart style one fresh
from the oven ready for us to use and
with that thank you by the way for the
few laughs with that I'm gonna fire up
cloud shell as I mentioned one
potentially our best-kept secrets and
let's get to developing our application
as clouds as cloud shell comes up
remember this is the VM that's
provisioned for you in your project it
comes with a number of tools built-in
I've done just a little bit of setup
work what I did was install the cloud
sequel proxy and set up a service
account so that I can authenticate or
connect to any cloud sequel instance in
my project so let me go ahead and start
up the proxy and then I'll show you what
a connection looks like okay so we'll
start up the proxy this looks good and
then I'm gonna go ahead and connect
using cloud shells built in Postgres
client and what you'll notice here as I
type this command is that I'm gonna tell
my cloud shell VM that the database is
running locally you see that I'm using
localhost as the address when I do that
the cloud sequel proxy intercepts and it
asks for my password which I'll put in
my very secure password here and we've
connected here let me make sure that we
have an empty database we just created
this database so let's make sure let's
that's post rest if it's empty
oops okay Postgres says I've got nothing
in my tables no tables at all which is a
good thing we've got a brand new
database and we're ready to use it for
our application what you've seen here is
that I've got good connectivity now from
my cloud shell VM to my database so with
that let's get our app started one of
the things to know you're more than
welcome to take pictures as we go along
everything Allen and I do today is
captured in a public code lab so you can
go through this yourself when you're
ready on your own PC what I will show
you is the application that we've
pre-built for you as part of the code
lab as I mentioned it's a Python
application a pretty small web app and
I'll download it now to our cloud shell
this is hosted right now on github and
again it's available for you as part of
the code lab we're writing this
application in Python but the language
itself doesn't matter as much for those
who are familiar with Python I'm going
to go ahead and set up a virtual
environment so we get our development
started
and we will also then go ahead and
activate the environment before we get
some necessary modules downloaded some
dependencies for our application okay so
I've got my environment activated now
let me go get some dependencies the
pre-built app comes with a requirements
list that you'll see as one of the files
and I can go and pip install a bunch of
dependency modules for those who are
familiar with Python and web frameworks
you'll notice that most of these
dependencies are flasks we're running a
flask web app today
okay so we've downloaded these let's go
ahead and test our application so I'm
gonna launch this directly within the
cloud shell VM and a really useful
feature here is that cloud shell builds
in a local web host environment so I can
test my web for my web application right
here from the cloud VM let's bring this
up and what you see is our app is at
least deployed as a test application
we're doing we're creating a mean gen
application which is very important to
Google and I will go ahead and create
the first meme let me put in our meme
here we'll see if our application can
happily talk to our database and there
we go we've got our first meme of the
day let me navigate back we'll just see
that the apps working we should just
have our one meme in recent okay so we
know now our application is working at
least for test purposes let's navigate
back to our cloud shell where I will go
ahead and kill our web host real quick
okay so now if I look at our other tab
when I do a refresh we should see yep
our web app is down so we don't have our
tests running anymore which is great
what we're gonna do now is start to use
docker we're gonna we're gonna
containerize our application now that
we've tested it and know that it's
running what you what you see here is
that our cloud shell VM has some docker
tools built in and I'm creating now a
container that we will go ahead and
deploy using docker within our cloud
shell VM as a way to test again and get
ready for our deployment to GTA II as
this is building Alan can you talk a
little bit about the general
to take an application like we have now
and get it to GAE
yeah so the first step is container
izing the application once this
containerized we're gonna push the image
into google container registry and
google container registry is a private
repo for you to store your container
images keep in mind that you can use
google container registry not only for
google kubernetes engine or google cloud
but you can use it from outside google
cloud as well so once this image is
stored in google container registry will
then be in a position to specify and and
build our kubernetes manifests to go
pull from container registry the images
that we want deployed and our pods
that's great so it looks like our
container has built I'm gonna go ahead
and run it in docker in our cloud shell
VM we've got that running and what this
should mean is that as I navigate back
to our test or a local web app if i
refresh this app we've now containerized
the application and ideally this should
work there's our meme gem back we stored
our first meme in the cloud sequel
database so it's been persisted and we
have a live containerized web app let me
navigate back to our cloud shell where
we can stop our docker image here and
we'll get a little bit of cleanup done
before now we get ready to move to
kubernetes so we've tested our
application we can Tanner eyes it and
now as Allen said we can start to get to
the fun part which is let's get this
deployed to kubernetes engine let me go
ahead and stop our docker run time here
there we go and we'll just double check
that indeed yep we've got this turned
off okay so let me kill off this tab I'm
going to also stop our cloud sequel
proxy
okay so we've gotten cleaned up here
Alan
let me now start to get ready to deploy
our application all right now comes the
fun part so we're actually going to go
in and create a google kubernetes engine
cluster and so as part of this Alan
we're starting to set up a bit of
credentials and we're gonna get ready to
deploy first our image to container
registry so what's happening here is
we're tagging the image that we're gonna
push into container registry and then
we're gonna issue a command to push this
image into GCR with those associated
tags and then the step before that was
really giving the docker run time the
credentials to be able to communicate
with Google container registry so what
you see here is we have a container
registry that's empty this is a new
project for us we don't have anything
that we've uploaded to contain a
registry yet but let's change that right
now and we'll start the the push to
container registry Alan as this starts
to work can you tell us in general
what's the benefit of using container
registry right so container registry is
really a secure way for you to store
your images and it can integrate with
any CI CD tooling that's available today
on the market it gives you consistent
experience for managing the lifecycle of
your container images and I as I
mentioned earlier this is not just a
google kubernetes engine service you can
use it from pretty much anywhere outside
of google kubernetes engine including
outside of Google Cloud we've done a
bunch of work around giving you the
ability to sign images really have like
attestation steps around the lifecycle
of you know images coming out of Google
container registry so it's really about
giving you that consistent and
verifiable and secure way of running and
managing your images as you look at
pushing them into different environments
and I think yeah the important point you
mentioned there is that while container
registry is very useful for using Google
Cloud products it can also be useful
when you're managing things well outside
of do
cloud correct yes okay so we're close
now to getting this pushed to our
container registry let's see as this
command finishes up if indeed we have
this uploaded up we've got our range our
meme gen a p-- and let's just take a
quick look looks like we uploaded it
just now okay great
next step in Alain is to actually create
our kubernetes cluster and before I do
that we'll just double check I don't
think we've created anything in this
project before looks like we've got a
pretty brand new project here let me go
ahead and issue this command and as this
is running let's talk through a few of
these parameters I'll bring up the UI
one thing to note here is that while we
are pretty CLI heavy in this
demonstration all of these things can be
done via a UI or even an API depending
on your preference I'll go ahead and
bring up the UI so when you talk through
a few the parameters so we're doing here
is we're actually creating a kubernetes
cluster that spans multiple availability
zones so think of an availability zones
as a fault domain right and the whole
goal here is our nodes will span
availability zones so when we deploy our
applications the replicas of the
application will be across you know
across the region so this gives us
higher availability and resiliency for
our application and you know let's just
walk through some of the configurations
associated with the cluster when you go
and create a cluster by default at zonal
so your control plane and the worker
nodes will all be in the same zone but
you have an option to change it to
regional and when you change it to
regional you now have the ability for
your control plane which is your master
to be replicated across three zones
within the region and then you specify
how many nodes you want for this
particular cluster and then those nodes
get deployed across the various zones
within that particular region I
mentioned earlier that google kubernetes
engine having been a GA product for
three years now we feel like we have the
most sophisticated most mature managed
kubernetes offering out there on the
market across any cloud typically when
there's a new version of kubernetes out
there
least every three months google
kubernetes engine has support for that
upstream version within a couple of
weeks so part of the process is you you
basically specify how many CPUs you want
for each machine type by default the
node operating system is container
optimized OS this is a chromium based
operating system that's very secure that
Google has created Google maintains if
you want more flexibility from a host
operating system standpoint we also
provide support for Ubuntu now if you
scroll down a bit more see you provide
information around how many nodes you
want your particular cluster and and
that's really around the de zero
experience now there's a whole bunch of
parameters really associated with the de
one experience so you can specify for
example I want Google to automatically
upgrade my nodes when there's a new
version or I want to be notified if
something happens to particular node it
fails I'd like Google kubernetes engine
to basically repair that node and fix
that node
same thing with patching you know all
that is very we have an SRE team that
basically manages a service and then
anything happens to your cluster that
SRE team will fix the problem there's
built-in integration with stag driver
logging and monitoring scroll down click
on more you can label your cluster you
can assign additional zones that you
want your nodes to be distributed across
there's auto scaling not only at the pod
level but at the node level so you can
integrate with the underlying manage
insist group framework for Google
compute engine to initiate a Auto scale
from your pod level all the way down to
your cluster level so we would add
additional nodes to your cluster if
there's resource contention
there's configure you can configure
persistent disk storage to your cluster
and basically map the persistent disk
resources depending on where your pods
are running which zone
that they're running in and then you
know one of the really cool features of
google prover Nettie's engine it's the
integration with cloud networking the
fact that Google cloud networking is a
global service you can assign a VP C to
your cluster and that cluster now has
the ability to take advantage of a
global network from a backbone
standpoint so you can actually have
clusters that are running in different
regions that are using the same vp c
that can actually talk to each other
pods can talk to each other that's a
very cool feature that's only available
in google cloud those are great points
Allanon we picked out a few parameters
specifically for this demonstration but
I think walking through the UI here
shows some of the flexibility you get
when you're creating clusters again if
you're new to kubernetes have a pass at
our code lab we think we've picked a few
good options but obviously there are
more to choose from
it looks like Ellen our cluster has been
created ICU I yeah so can you click on
compute engine yeah let's take a look
here because you mentioned that
underpinning all of this are a set of
VMs yes so you see these VMs now that
are created they're six in total and
they're created there's two in each zone
so this gives you the resiliency now for
your applications that your application
can be scheduled depending on how many
replicas you specify
they'll be scheduled across the
availability zones for the cluster okay
so let's let's continue on we promised
some scalability etc let's get this
started to set up here so the next thing
we're gonna do is we're going to get the
credentials for that cluster and we're
gonna store it in our cube config file
this is a local file
so what cube config does is it provides
kubernetes has a command-line interface
that comes with the project called cube
control or cube CTL so once you have the
credentials you can now use cube control
to manage your cluster and basically
operate against any of the api's the
kubernetes api s that are available and
that's what we're going to do from here
forward we're going to use cube control
to manage and operate it and deploy
applications on our cluster it's a great
point I'll start I'll get started with
tube control by setting up a couple
secrets I'm going to set up two secrets
here the first will be to to make sure
that our application can use the cloud
sequel proxy to connect to our cloud
sequel instance the second secret you'll
notice is my user name and database
password so that our application can log
in so we've got our two secrets created
here what I have done before we started
was modify the Yamma file that we're
going to use for deployment so let me
just get the new DML file put in place
here and then we can take a quick look
at the yam we'll file Alan just to show
folks what that what's inside of this
one yeah so this is a deployment file
this is a kubernetes artifact right it's
a specification that you define it
describes your application and what
we're doing here is we are deploying a
pod that contains the mem gem container
as well as the cloud sequel proxy as a
sidecar container so a pod is really
about packaging containers together that
have very much a dependency on each
other right so anytime you have multiple
containers that need to live and die
together or perhaps need to share local
IPC or share storage you put those in a
pod and it becomes a unit of scale when
you create a pod in kubernetes every pod
is assigned an IP address so we have
this notion of IP per pod and these are
internal addresses that are basically
pulled out of the sitter block ranges
that are assigned for every node within
a kubernetes cluster by default every
node gets a slash 24 sitter range and
when a pod comes up on that particular
node it takes an IP from that range
that's great so I just used our llamo
file to start the creation and what
we'll look for is that our pods get
created as we'd expect as you mentioned
with two containers correct so think of
a deployment as a kubernetes controller
right so with the deployment kubernetes
brings this notion of a declarative
model right so within a deployment you
specify your desired state what you'd
like the world to look like for your
application so how many instances you
can specify certain labeling associated
with your application a controller is
constantly monitoring the actual state
of your application so if something bad
happens a node goes down a pod goes down
the controller will look at the actual
state and then we'll compare the with
the desired state that you specify in
that deployment file and we'll always
ensure that your actual state equals
your desired state this is a beauty in
terms of being able to deploy an
application that's highly available
resilient and not have to worry about
you know ensuring the you know the
application is number of instances if
something goes wrong kubernetes will
always kick in with health checks to
ensure that your actual state equals to
that state that your application needs
it's really a notion of infrastructure
by configuration file in this case yeah
so what we're doing now is you know we
talked about the whole notion of a pod
gets an internal IP address but let's
say you want that pod to be accessed
from the outside world and what Brad
just did is exposed the deployment as a
load balanced service so what this
actually does is it creates a service
object and it creates a GCE load
balancer assigns that an external IP
dress and creates the routes associated
with that external IP address back to
the pods the internal pods that are
running in your cluster in our case here
we only had one pod that was running but
think of a case where you have 10 pods
running across multiple machines once
you hit that external IP they'll get
round-robin to the appropriate pods
running across your cluster
so as you can see here we have an
external IP address that's been assigned
and Brett can now hit it and basically
it should show the application and for
those of you that have phones and can
want to hit that address please go in
and mean yeah I think this is really the
moment of truth we're gonna find out
right now if we deployed this app
publicly it looks like on our end that
this app is good we're gonna
double-check our database here looks
like our loan meme is still there so as
Alan mentioned if you have mobile
devices and a pretty good set of eyes
here to read this URL we can we can read
it out to you let me let me zoom this in
if we want here let's just see I'm
struggling to zoom the IP address I will
read it quickly 35.226 dot 10.1 49 I
suspect there are many great memes in
this audience far better than mine and
to sweeten the deal a bit Alan and I
have have come armed with $500 Google
Cloud credit coupons we're happy to dole
those out to folks who create some of
the best memes and and hit us up after
the event one thing I will note here is
that this session is being recorded and
will be broadcast on the internet so
let's please keep the memes as tasteful
as we can but I look forward to seeing
what you come up with we talk to Alan at
the beginning about auto-scaling or
about building a scalable application
let's start to add an auto scaler to our
configuration and then we'll see if
between the audience maybe ourselves we
can generate some load let's do that all
right
and I'm looking forward by the way -
whoa keeps coming we're gonna go back to
that tab okay so we just add an auto
scaler yes so we're doing right now is
we're creating a horizontal pod
autoscaler object and what this does is
it defines a certain set of thresholds
so what we're doing here is we're saying
if the combined CPU utilization across
all my pods increases above 50%
I'd like you to auto scale so if we take
a look at our HPA object right now
there's
no there's really no load there's
there's no load at this point we should
really see this number at almost close
to zero so we'll let this get
initialized here and then oh it looks
like we've got a little bit of load
courtesy of the audience thank you let's
let's push this a bit Alan and I have
set up a VM that has an application
called hey installed hey is a web load
generator let me bring this up bear with
me just a moment we'll add our load to
the mix and please keep your memes
coming we'll see if we can knock down
our application here let's just take a
look I'm going to bring up a terminal to
this VM and we'll get our load kicked
off and then we'll see how kubernetes
handles things and by the way I'm
excited to get back to the tab to see
what you all are creating so it'll take
a minute or so for this to come up and
what will actually happen is the
horizontal pod autoscaler will be
monitoring the the load usage coming in
and then as soon as there's an average
CPU utilization above 50% you should see
a pod auto scale so we're talking about
auto scaling here at the pod level but
keep in mind we've also enabled cluster
auto scaling for the kubernetes engine
cluster so if for some reason we
exceeded the resources that are
available from a node standpoint
kubernetes engine will actually
provision a new node a new set of nodes
in our in our zones as well okay so
let's take a quick look and just see how
many pods we have we still have our our
lone pod running hopefully our our load
generator has started to take effect
let's just let's just see here so we're
getting it close to our target here
we'll see if between the audience and
our load generating rack we can ratchet
this up what we're looking for is a
number it's a load number coming in that
is in excess of our 50 percent target
when that happens that tells kubernetes
app engine alan to start to scale by
adding more pods adding more web
front-ends behind our load balancer so
that we can scale to meet the load of
our now very popular application
let's take a quick look here and see
where we're at still at 50 we'll see if
we can get our load gentle spinning up a
bit more and these thresholds you can
also hear we're using CPU you can also
specify memory and we also have an
option for you to find custom metrics so
number of requests queue lengths things
of that nature to trigger these
horizontal pod auto scaling so there we
go two hundred and sixty six percent so
we've exceeded the threshold and
kubernetes now is is is auto scaling the
pods and these pods are being Auto
scaled across the availability zones and
there we go so now we have four pods
that are running within our region and
this is act the actual state that the
application is running in and the
controller is monitoring us looks like
our app is still up in pretty healthy
even under this load let's give it a
little more to work with I'm gonna say
that something bad happens to let's just
say our original pod here yep so if we
kill a pod the controller will check to
see that hey I've got only three pods
running I should have four and we'll
automatically create a new pod so that
you constantly have that enough capacity
to serve your application all right it
looks like we've fired up one and it's a
replacement I'm gonna see if I can give
it a little more work we'll kill one
more pod just to see what happens and
while we kill that let's go take a look
at our web app looks like our web app is
still living pretty healthy Wow we've
got some one script this that may be
worth a coupon and of itself okay looks
like our web front-ends are handling
this load pretty well let's imagine now
that we have a problem on the database
side so I'm gonna go over to our cloud
sequel instance and let's give it a
problem
I'll start by noting that our cloud
sequel instance is happily existing in
Zone B of us enter one zone Bravo
let's ask cloud sequel to fail over this
instance
initiate a failover here we'll start
this and cloud sequel says this
operation starting so what we've done
here is simulate a failure typically
cloud sequel will be health checking our
instance and if for some reason the
instance becomes unhealthy cloud sequel
will trigger this failover automatically
here because we're we just want to show
what this looks like for our application
we're testing a failover by manually
triggering it
so cloud sequel thinks the failover
operation is in progress
when this happens our application
attempts to connect to the database and
it fails so what's going on right now is
cloud sequel had previously provisioned
our primary instance in Zone B a
provision to standby instance in some
other zone within the region it always
makes sure it's in a different zone a
different failure domain cloud sequel is
making sure that our primary instance
our old primary instance has come down
won't serve any more right requests and
then as bringing up our standby instance
after doing so it's going to move the
name and the IP address of our primary
instance over to the standby instance
making it primary as well this is
important because to your application
when a failover occurs it looks simply
like a database goes down and then comes
back up there's no need to build in
failover logic to the application cloud
sequel is orchestrating those mechanics
itself after it's bringing up our new
primary instance to life cloud sequels
going off and building another standby
instance and yet another zone to make
sure that our new primary instance is
protected usually this whole failover
scenario with cloud sequel for Postgres
takes about 45 seconds so let's check
back in and see what cloud sequel has to
say cloud sequel looks like it's healthy
again and we'll try to note now our
primary instance is no longer in zone b
we're now in zone f as in Foxtrot so
we've failed from zone B to zone F let's
see if our application is happy again
with any luck we'll do a refresh here
and it looks like we're back Wow well
done so what we've seen here Alan is
that we've injected some
in our application and it looks like
we've successfully recovered we've coped
with the load from our VM as well as
from our audience here with that let me
let me switch back now to our slides and
we'll do a little bit of wrap-up so
again I think a couple key points in our
architecture here you saw the auto
scaling nature of kubernetes engine as
we increased load kubernetes
automatically added pods on our behalf
you also saw how kubernetes engine and
clouds sequel handle failures our
application was down for about 45
seconds in total without sequel was
failing over it wasn't down at all when
kubernetes pods failed the upshot for
Alan and I is that we didn't get a text
or an email about this this happened
without us taking any intervention and
you all are happily creating memes again
so this I think really speaks to the
fault tolerant nature of this
architecture we want to wrap up today
with just a few next steps as a starting
point please try this out yourself with
the code lab that's available online if
you haven't used Google Cloud before
there is a free trial for folks who are
new to signing up you get 300 free trial
dollars if you created a great meme and
want to show it to Alan reactor the
presentation we'd love to give you 500
more dollars to play with with
kubernetes engine cloud sequel and other
products we're early in our conference
this week I have a few presentation
picks for you first is a selfish plug
for a presentation tomorrow about cloud
sequel migrating to cloud sequel with
low downtime if you have databases and
you want to get the cloud sequel take a
look at this presentation two others on
the list
Alan are computing with power not
previously possible with bigquery and
compute engine a bit of a tongue twister
but I think it's gonna be a great
presentation and lastly if you enjoyed
the nature of this presentation building
an app together we think you'll really
like cross-platform mobile app build
with firebase that's dev 222 later in
the week
[Music]